Let’s say it’s the early 15th century
and you’re a young citizen of a northern
German city of Rostock, playing the new online
game Raid Shadow Legends.
You begin this 3D online RPG by choosing a
starter hero to fight your battles with and
down the line can get many more heroes from
the summoning portal to build up a full team.
With this rag tag group you can then complete
quests, challenges and progress through the
campaign.
The graphics and animations of this game are
great looking, smoothless, the art style has
this delightful feeling of a sort of cartoonish
reality and you can get this charmingly looking
game right now on IOS, Android and PC with
cross platform support.
That means you can play with your friends
no matter what potato they’re playing on.
So what are you waiting for, as part of the
New Player Program there’s a special link
in the description that will give you 50k
silver to start off with, and a free epic
champion to put in to that rag tag team you
plan to conquer the world with.
Good luck and thank you for Raid Shadow Legends
for sponsoring this video.
Rostock is a very rich autonomous Hanseatic
city within the duchy of Mecklenburg and is
a valuable ship building port for the Hansa.
Outside of Rostock, the hanseatic league has
many members.
With its headquarters in Lubeck it operates
a very wide trade network across numerous
northern European cities.
Some cities are members of the league just
like Rostock, others just have permanent representatives
of the league living in their city ensuring
a streamlined flow of trade goods.
And some cities which are very important to
the Hanseatic league but aren’t autonomous
and are under the domain of a foreign monarch,
meaning the cities can’t join the league
fully, have what the Hansa calls a Kontor.
Which is an independent part of a city, with
extra privileges granted by the local ruler
that allows them to live under their own German
rules.
Local rulers were usually strong-armed by
the League to give these extra privileges
to the Kontors, because Hansa was a very powerful
and rich entity in medieval northern Europe,
that rarely took no for an answer.
Plus they brought a lot of trade to an area
which was always a plus for any local monarch.
However going back to Rostock recently the
dukes of Mecklenburg have been trying to curb
the cities autonomy and bring it more into
the fold of their influence.
Which is a very similar situation that many
other Hanseatic cities have found themselves
under recently.
None the less you don’t care for grand politics
that seem to move very slowly, taking decades
to resolve sometimes.
Plus the Hanseatic League seems to be at the
height of its power, it’s not like from
now on it’s going to gradually shrink due
to the exertion of more direct control by
local rulers and being pushed out by national
globalized trade companies that do business
across multiple continents, some of which
you don’t even know exist yet.
That’s not gonna happen.
You’re living here and now in Rostock, looking
to make money looking for a job.
And there’s no better paying employer in
the city, than the Hanseatic League, a medieval
european trading guild of which your city
is a proud member of and from which the Hanseatic
league recruits young boys from.
Ehhh Young boys?
Ou yes I forgot to mention you’re most likely
12, but that’s fine, it’s the middle ages,
so this is nothing unusual.
With the offer of a home, a stable income,
an education, and a possibility to see the
world, you don’t hesitate to sign up.
Now usually young boys are recruited by the
Hansa because one of their family members,
mostly their dad, is already a merchant in
the League.
However this is not always the case so for
the sake of argument let's say your parents
died of a plague and one of your very close
family friends was a Hanseatic merchant who
helped you get signed up.
Now Hansa didn’t only recruit 12 year olds,
you could have technically signed up at any
point in your life but the older you where
the less likely you where to get in.
With that said, many young adults, usually
through family connections or their own influence,
often easily got into the League.
But I digress.
Before the Hansa accepts you, you have to
fulfill certain criteria.
Are you male, check.
Do you speak Low German, check.
Are you Low German, check.
Have you lived in Rostock for more than 7
years, check.
Are you willing to remain unmarried/unattached
for a certain amount of time usually 7 to
10 years?
You might think this is a ridiculous question
since you’re twelve, but you’re actually
legally allowed to marry since 12 in most
of Medieval Europe.
Even though this was rarely practiced by females
who usually married between 14 and 20, and
almost never practiced by males who usually
got married in their early twenties.
But it did happen, so … sure what ta hell
check.
Are you young, healthy, strong, basically
well suited for harsh manual labor, check.
Can you be trusted with leagues trade secrets,
well if your YouTube comments are anything
to go by than no, but I’ll give it to you
anyways, check.
These aren’t the only criteria and there
where many more criterias which changed depending
on what city you’re being recruited from,
what period of the Hanseatic league you’re
being recruited in, or just the literal preferences
of the person who’s doing the particular
recruitment.
Nonetheless you pass all these criteria and
are awarded the title of Stubenjunge, office
boy or office helper and the league decides
you’ll be sent to live for 7 to 10 years
in one of its most northern Kontors in Bergen.
You promptly leave Rostock on one of the leagues
merchant ships, wondering if you’ll ever
see the city again, but are nonetheless excited
for what lies ahead.
The reasons why the Hanseatic League even
operated in Bergen are multiple.
The largest reason being the cod trade.
Cod which is so numerous in the North See
unlike the herring of the Baltic sea which
Hansa relied upon before expanding its trade
northward is a much less oily fish, meaning
after being wind dried unlike the herring
it can last for years before going rotten.
And the longer you can keep your trade good
liquid, the better.
Plus on top of being a fairly large city with
plenty of access to the local North Sea fisheries
willing to sell their product, Bergen at this
time also had a sizeable German population.
These Germans were mostly artizens like, cobblers,
tailors, etc. that came to Bergen due to the
lack of well made homegrown Norwagen goods.
These two aspects and multiple otherones meant
that Bergen was the perfect city in Norway
for the Hansa to set up shop, and so they
did.
You arrive in Bergen and the ship drops you
off on the north side of the harbor, the first
thing you see are large colorful wooden buildings,
surrounded by palisades, guarded by dogs and
seemingly separate from the rest of the city.
What you see, is the Bergen Kontor, known
as Bryggen.
The isolated nature of the Bryggen from the
rest of Bergen is on purpose.
The Hanseatic League wants you to focus on
your work and nothing but the work, everything
else is a distraction.
And even though this is the official standing
of the League it is rarely fully enforced.
The Bergen citizens often participate in Bryggens
social celebrations, the Bryggen merchants
often have close Bergen friends, and the Kontor
even operates a public wine cellar for the
locals.
Nonetheless you’re showed that each colorful
house is called a Yard which is where members
of the league live, conduct business, have
social gatherings, etc.
Each Yard is also divided depending on the
geographical area where the merchants come
from.
So all merchants from Westphalia live in one
Yard while all merchants from Lower Saxony
live in another Yard, etc.
Naturally since you’re from Rostock, you
are put in to the Yard where all merchants
from Mecklenburg and Pomerania live.
Every Yard has a council comprised of all
the senior merchants living in it, the council
elects a house Master in charge of basically
everything that happens in the Yard.
The Kontor as a whole also has three elected
elderman responsible for the entire Kontor
and the communication with the League itself,
and lastly the elderman are advised by an
elected council of 18 deputies.
Each Yard also has its own flag and some amazing
name like, The Unicorn, The Golden Shoe or
my personal favorite, The Sisters.
So you're a newcomer to the Kontor and the
first night at the Sisters Yard you are promptly
hazed, which includes but isn’t limited
to, just simply getting punched and kicked,
being pelted by pieces of crap, getting ice
cold water poured on you and or being thrown
into the local well.
After surviving that, you’re officially
part of the The Sisters Yard and of the Bergen
Kontor and you can start working your way
up the Hanseatic Corporate ladder.
Your official work as Stubenjunge involves
cleaning the Yard, the bathrooms, the ships,
and also attending classes in the dining hall.
Here you’re taught how to read and write
in german and sometimes latin, do basic math
bookkeepings, and various merchant laws and
dues and don’t of the industry.
You live in one room with 5 to 7 other young
members of the Kontor and are not allowed
to talk to the senior members of the League
unless spoken to.
None the less you do your work, your studies
and get involved in the very close knit social
community of the Kontor.
Three years have passed and you have been
upgraded to a Bootsjunge, also there’s no
better way of putting it.
You’re a teenager now.
As a bootsjunge you no longer have to clean
the Kontor or the ships but are in charge
of taking care of the boats, which includes
everything from maintaining the boats, to
making sure the boats are ready whenever needed,
and when they’re not needed making sure
they are stored offshore so they wont be stolen.
You’re further now required to be part of
the rowing crew of the boats as well.
Plus, when the fishing season ends and Norwagens
from all around Norway come to Bergen to sell
their seasons catch, you’re awakened at
4 am and are put to work to whole all the
new fish bought by the Hansa.
You do this until 9 pm with only 2 short breaks
for breakfast and lunch.
Also now that you’re 15 or maybe even when
you were younger, it’s very hard to gauge
the average age of sexual activity in the
middle ages, you start to participate in an
act that many other guys from the Kontor participate
in as well.
And that is to sneak out at night to the street
that lies just north of Bryggen.
This is because the street north of Bryggen
is known as the Bergens red light district.
And since the Kontor is filled with young
males, all of whom vowed not to get married
or romantically attached for their 7 to 10
year stay at the Hansa Kontor, as one historian
puts it, “there was a large overdose of
testosterone that needed an outlet to prevent
violent clashes”.
The league officially throwned upon these
practices, because as they put it, you “might
tell the native woman under the influence
of her charm, as well as that of liquor, things
she had best not know.”
those being the Hanseatic trade secrets.
But despite this, in practice, it was all
very much tolerated by the entire league.
There’s even a law found in one of the books
at the London Kontor, which states that if
two or more merchants were planning to bring
women to the confines of the Yard, they had
to decide prior to entering the kontor which
woman shall lay with whom as to not repeat
an incident that occurred previously.
Which presumably was a fight between two guys
over a girl.
Back in Bergen another 3 years have passed
and you have been promoted to the title of
Gesell, which in english would be something
like journeyman or junior partner.
This basically means you work directly under
one of the Masters also known as just a Merchant
in the Kontor.
You go with him on sailing expeditions, to
business meetings, and sometimes you’re
even allowed to make your own small business
decisions.
You gather valuable knowledge about how the
Hanseatic league operates, what are its rules
etc.
After a couple of years of this and almost
at the end of your 7 to 10 year stay at the
Bergen Kontor you’re finally promoted to
the status of a Meister.
Basically meaning master in German.
This means you’re finally allowed to make
your own way in life and the League.
You no longer have to work under any merchant,
you can conduct your own business within the
league, make your own trade deals, and even
participate in the Kontor and the League elections.
You can also run for offices if you want,
like Hausmeister, the head of a Yard, the
Achtzehner, one of the 18 councillors of a
Kontor, or Olderleute, one of the three elderman
in the kontor.
If you are very ambitious you can even become
a representative of a Hanseatic city on the
Hansetag, the highest Hanseatic Office which
meets in Lubeck and basically has the final
say in every Hanseatic affair.
But hold all those thoughts, because you’re
technically not done yet.
Going from a Gesell to a Meister you have
go through not one, not two, but three initiation
ceremonies, which in Bryggen, are known as
the Hanseatic games.
So let's begin.
“The Smoke Test”
The first initiation ceremony is a spectacle
for the entire city.
Crowdes from all over Bergen gather to witness
your hazing.
“(Cough) ok I can’t do that voice for
the entire time sorry”.
So the first initiation ceremony is a spectacle
for the entire city.
Crowdes from all over Bergen gather to witness
your hazing.
The boats in the Harbor are decorated in colorful
flags, ornaments, etc. also each Yard is proudly
waving its own special flag as well.
Senior members of the Kontor pass in a procession
through the city, followed by the Stubenjungens
with buckets.
The Stubenjungens gathered into the buckets
all the filthiest things they can find on
the streets as the procession goes along,
sometimes even being helped by the locals
who brought their own dirty things to put
in the bucket.
The parade is also accompanied by a jester,
masked figures, and two people entertaining
the crowd, dressed as the poorest peasants
imaginable.
Ou and you along with other initiates are
there as well.
Once the procession enters the guild hall
of the Bryggen you are tied and hauled up
into the chimney.
After that the Stubenjungens drop all the
contents of their buckets into the fireplace
and a fire is started.
During this time you are repeatedly lowered
from the chimney and questioned on various
merchant knowledge.
When the Senior Merchants see you are at the
bring of suffocation you are promptly taken
out of the chimney and dosed with 6 buckets
of ice cold water.
Congratulations you have passed the first
task.
“The Water Test”
There is a giant banquet held to your and
other initiates honor.
There is plenty of drinking, eating, singing,
etc.
However when this stops, you’re promptly
stripped off from all of your clothing, this
is so that everyone can make sure you’re
a male because allegedly one time a woman
was almost admitted to the league (ha the
horror).
Once completely naked you’re taken out on
a boat in to the harbor where you’re thrown
into the ice cold water.
Everytime you try to get back up into the
boat you’re beaten back into the water with
a stick.
Keep in mind while all of this is happening
everyone is quite drunk.
This continues on for a couple of minutes
until you’re brought back up into the boat
and back to the Kontor.
Congratulations you have passed the second
task.
“The Flogging Test”
Happening on a separate day than the actual
flogging, you and other initiates are required
to go on a procession through the town to
the St Mary’s church cemetery where the
locals have already gathered in large numbers.
You and other initiates then take turns and
climb on a tree, from which you yell out in
minute details, every sexual act you had with
every woman whilst at Bergen, apparently the
locals found this very amusing.
On the day of the last initiation, another
procession of the most senior members of the
Kontor, and drummers, go through the town
in the morning to the nearby forest where
they cut the most painfully looking branches
from a tree.
Then they come back to the Kontor where they
give an address to all the initiates about
the importance of the league, it’s community
and that you can still back out if you don’t
want to be a member.
After that another giant banquete is held
at noon with music, singing, drinking, etc.
Apparently special care is taken at this time
that all the initiates are very intoxicated
by the time of the flogging.
Than the branches that have been cut earlier
in the day are given to the most muscular
member of the Kontor and the initiates are
wiped by them until it’s deemed by the senior
members of the Kontor “that’s enough”.
After this the initiates are given even more
alcohol during which if they pass out, they’re
thrown into the local well.
If you survived, congratulations, you have
passed the third and last task.
You’re now officially a full fledged merchant
of the hanseatic League.
I would also like to point out that even though
very uncommon some members did died during
these initiation ceremonies.
But you don’t have to worry about that.
You survived and you can now either stay in
the Kontor and run for an office there, return
back to Rostock and conduct trade there, or
go anywhere else to conduct business within
the Hanseatic league.
You can now also finally marry someone and
maybe you found a girl you fancy while you
were in Bergen, so you’ll decide to stay.
Who knows the choice is yours.
Now before this video ends I want to emphasize
this was just one representation of a life
that a Hanseatic merchant might have had.
The Hanseatic League was a giant medieval
trade guild spanning multiple centuries.
The life experiences of a Hansa merchant in
the 13th century differed widely from a Hansa
merchant in the 16th century.
In the later half of the leagues existence,
there where even instances of German speaking
Slavic and Baltic people becoming merchants
within the guild.
Plus even in this small snippet of time in
the early 15th century that I have shown in
this video, the experiences of each merchant
in the Hansa where very different as well.
For example the Bergen kontor was notorious
even within the Hansa for it’s hazing, closed
off community, and unique administrative structure.
The London Kontor on the other hand was a
much more open ended community without such
rigidly defined social structures.
They were still there, just not as harsh.
In the Novgorod kontor young merchants where
even encouraged to live amongst Russian farmers
so they learned the language, because that
would be beneficial for their trade later
on.
And many merchants who signed up with the
Hanseatic league didn’t even live in a Kontor,
they simply worked within a well known medieval
apprenticeship structure under a merchant
“master”, going from one Hansa city to
another Hansa city and conducting in layman's
terms, trade.
They did this until they reached a stage to
be elevated to a Master within the Hansa themselves,
after which just like you becoming a Master
in the Kontor they could conduct trade on
their own anywhere in the Hanseatic League.
There are so many variables within the Hanseatic
League that changed depending on many other
variables that the only way I saw it possible
to present how the Hanseatic League operated
was through showing just one specific time
period in one specific geographical area.
Otherwise this video would have had too many
asterisks attached to everything I said.
Hope you enjoyed the video, don’t forget
I have Patreon you can support me on and there’s
more information, clarifications and corrections
in the description as always.
My name is M. Laser and stick around for History.